we're gonna wrap it up in a little bit
here but i think we've kind of solved it
i mean i think we solved it dude uh body
armor fashion lines we gotta arm up yeah
uh we gotta have these schools
completely armed everyone armed all the
time including the kids watching each
other taking all these factors into
account yeah and then you need uh
surveillance systems too you need
surveillance at all times yeah at all
times yeah and uh yeah and that'll keep
everyone free well at least it'll give
pedophiles some jobs where they're doing
some good why not watch the kids here's
a crazy idea yeah pedophiles
outside the schools with guns
the pedophiles care about the kids
nobody loves them more pedophiles care
about the kids they can protect the
schools with guns nobody is going to
care for the well-being what about an
army of pedophiles around the school
with guns i love it
solved
give pedophiles guns yeah let them arm
the schools yeah and maybe uh we go back
to castles where there's like a
it's not a bad idea to just have a like
put schools in places geographically
that are harder to get to so all the
kids are in school you bring the draw
bridge up right lava i think the honest
answer is also like why have schools
when you could just send kids to work
houses and work
that's probably why this is happening
there was no shootings when there were
workhouses in london let's get these
kids back to work clean in chimneys at
four
it's a great it's a good idea yeah i
mean again folks this is you know it's a
you know
it's an issue but it's not that big of a
deal it's not it's not a big deal not as
big of a deal as a lot of other things
yes there's a lot of other problems that
are a bigger deal what do ricky gervais
say there's all kinds of what did ricky
gervais say is a big big problem i don't
think it's a big you know listen people
are gonna die yeah and some of them are
gonna be young yeah
what are you gonna do there's nothing
are you gonna ban child death it's
really not as big of a deal as are you
gonna ban child death you can't ban
child death yeah and you know it's like
we we're all really more concerned about
what's going to happen in this verdict
with johnny depp and amber hurt oh god
what's a bigger deal what's a bigger
deal that's right what do people care
about more really yeah i think they care
more about that well it's more fun it's
more fun this is very depressing with
the kids and the the people always
getting shot it's very depressing yeah
it is fun a fake faked i needed it i
called it i called it months ago i said
we needed a trial
to get us out of this i said
maybe kanye would like kill kim and pete
or something i said we needed a trial
yeah to get us out of the coven malays
and it was depp heard and i didn't even
know
uh amber heard breaks down on stand i'm
getting thousands of death threats and
he hears shed get more
um but you know i said we needed a trial
i was correct we absolutely need a trial
we need trials on every channel we need
uh prank shows on every channel yeah and
we need people inside please don't leave
your house
ever yeah at all just watch this new
form of entertainment it's great because
it's like it's like soccer there's very
few commercial breaks it goes for 20
hours yeah this is the longest trial
that's great i mean this shooting will
be out of the news in an hour
this won't even be relevant when it's
released on saturday in two days this
episode won't be there'll be another
shooting by then yeah but this that hurt
thing has gone on for as long as i can
remember i think it's six weeks i feel
like i've grown up with these people
yeah i care more about them than i do my
own family yeah and it's not even close
yes i care more about amber hurt and
johnny depp than these kids that got
shot because i've been with them longer
it's just on more it's great yeah and i
mean it's just it's just what it is and
it's the only thing left really that
hasn't been done right it's like uh
trials yeah celebrities that are real
that are drug addicts that beat each
other up yeah for your entertainment and
you know what's fun about it they're
rich so there's butlers and maids and
nannies and assistants and like weird
types of things and there's coachella in
the hills in australia and we're in
we're in italy or whatever they're doing
and they're you know it's fun to hear
about somebody getting beaten
in a nice area it's for once it's a good
it's a good time to be a body language
expert yeah it's really good they're
doing real well they're doing real well
providing a lot of commentary for this
yeah well i mean folks we've come up
with the solutions i don't know what you
want me to do i mean you know
unfortunately
this is what happens you can homeschool
your kids and you can shoot them yeah
don't go out but it's not just school so
don't go outside well you don't need to
yeah with an instacart and postmates
yeah you don't really need no no truly
now you don't need to go out don't need
to be outside you don't need to if you
go to a national park you get abducted
if you go to the grocery store you make
a shot in the face
you don't need to go outside there's
you have streaming services you have
people that are willing to brave the
elements to bring you nachos and they're
gonna get killed
so at the end of the day there's no real
reason you need to leave your house it's
not a big deal everything should be like
going to
the airport there should be
checkpoints
and metal detectors every you shouldn't
nobody should have their shoes on ever
there's one safe place in america
there's one safe place in america
and it's austin
texas paradise so if you want to live in
a place where was this shooting how far
away from austin uh so it's 30 minutes
or 90 miles west of san antonio so
that's about three hours i guess okay
yeah yeah but now google austin shooting
i bet yeah i bet nothing comes up let's
see no austin i bet nothing comes out
austin's just weird at news here it's
all gonna be
what happened here
man shot dead by officers after he
allegedly pointed a gun at people from
his truck
that was 17 hours ago and dead after
opening fire on officers from pickup
truck in southeast austin
this is the same thing
yeah teen arrested after shooting death
in south austin parking lot outside la
fitness that was three days ago half of
deadliest u.s shootings were in texas oh
it's weird it's weird
you know it's weird when you go
it's not a great
it's not great it's weird when you go to
like the uh the
the uh very like liberal i guess as far
as right
gun laws go like you can meaning you can
have a gun you go to those places but
they have signs in all the places where
you go that's don't bring your gun in
here right you're like wait a second i
thought i was in north carolina what do
you mean i can't bring my gun to the
opera right
why can i not have my gun
you notice that all the stores have
places uh you no guns no guns you're
like dude aren't we in north what's the
point yeah of having the gun if i can't
bring it inside well here's the deal i
mean we've been a bunch of buffoons and
goofballs but my suggestion to everyone
with children is to just [ __ ] not get
so attached
my name is tim dillon this special the
special that we're talking about is
called mom love yeah and we need a lot
less of mom and dad love yeah
janice pappas is on youtube right now
mom love it's a full hour special very
very funny